hello
and welcome to pi data global
and my talk on thrifty machine learning
this talk is going to be about
how to cultivate more economical and
cost
conscious modeling habits for machine
learning practitioners
and data science teams
there are three sections of the talk the
first section of the talk
is about where machine learning has been
the last five years five to ten years
in the applied kind of commercial
machine learning space
the second part of the talk is going to
be about
um how to be thriftier
in our machine learning practices and
then
the end of the talk is a bit of a
thought experiment
which i hope you'll join me on thinking
about um
how things might change if we shifted
our perspective
um in terms of the goals of machine
learning uh towards
sort of a more cost conscious thrifty
uh perspective so
first to introduce myself my name is dr
rebecca bilbrow
i live on the east coast of the united
states of america
and i work at a company called unisys
where i do applied machine learning i'm
also the
author of the book applied text analysis
with python which is an o'reilly book
and i'm the creator and maintainer of
the
python yellow yellowbrick library which
is a library for doing
machine learning diagnostics for
data scientists if you're looking for me
on any of the social platforms uh
i am rebecca bilbrow kind of on every
platform so i'm pretty easy to find so
in terms of where we find ourselves uh
these days
um the phrase for me that comes to mind
is the phrase an embarrassment of riches
and when i think about this phrase the
imagery that comes to mind are
chandeliers
and flutes of champagne and the great
gatsby
and fancy things um what an
embarrassment of riches means
is you know a time where you have more
than you need there's an overabundance
of things and i think that that actually
is a pretty apt
description of where we have found
ourselves
in the last few years of doing machine
learning in an applied context
and if you think about what has really
caused this over abundance i think
really
one of the main answers is open source
software we have never had more
open source software than we do right
now and we've never had
access to more machine learning code in
the open
than we've ever had before you know
there are new
machine learning libraries that come out
all the time
that can help us do specialized types of
models to assess the quality of our
models
and assist us with the diagnostics
process like yellow brick
but there's really been never been more
open source software than there there is
right now
we've also never had access to more
uh compute resources than we do at this
very moment
um you know whether that is kind of
running code
uh on cpus and your your laptop
or if you have sort of a custom rig that
you've built
for doing machine learning that has
souped up with gpus or if you
have access to the company credit card
and you
are um you know running code on very
expensive
tpus in the cloud you know these are all
at least theoretically um kind of
realistic ways of doing machine learning
these days
um and then the other thing is we've
never
had access to more opinions
than we do right now right we've never
had access to
more ideas and opinions about how we
should be doing machine learning
how we should be spending our time doing
machine learning and spending our
resources and our money doing
machine learning whether that is you
know reading
the archive or exploring
kind of q a on reddit or
kaggle or stack overflow you know if you
are reading articles
on medium we have kind of this over
abundance of opinions about how we
should be
using open source software and
how we should be using those compute
resources
unfortunately um you know this sort of
confluence
of abundance i you know
has led to i think some practices that
are not particularly efficient
when it comes to time and money um you
know there's this expression a fool in
their money
are soon parted um right and i think
that
um in the next uh few years uh
for people who have not already started
to experience um
the kind of economic impacts of covet
19.
um many of us are are going to start
feeling these and we're going to start
feeling them on machine learning teams
particularly at companies where there's
been some kind of discretionary budget
you know that sort of imagined well if
we let the data scientists
continue tinkering for long enough they
will make something great
i imagine that these budgets are going
to
start shrinking and it's therefore going
to become more and more important for us
as data scientists and machine learning
practitioners to really prove out our
value
and clearly kind of explain
um how we are going to deliver value
uh without ballooning budgets
uh here's kind of a you know i think a
good
um theme for kind of going into this
idea of thrifty
machine learning that you know what we
would like to be doing
is sowing frugality um and and by sewing
frugality what we'll do is we will
uncouple ourselves from some of the
tools and practices that
now constrain our ability to do machine
learning
and are constraining our ability to do
machine learning in
a cost-conscious way and hopefully if we
if we can kind of solve frugality
we will yield the sort of golden harvest
um
so let's think about some uh with you
know my best practices
uh for doing machine learning on a
budget um
so you know when we say machine learning
um
we mean actually a lot of different
things but let's kind of
take a simple case where what we're
talking about is supervised
machine learning right so with
supervised machine learning
we have sort of three things we have to
do we need to
um get labeled training data then we
need to
take the um the features of that data
and do
some kind of transformation some kind of
engineering to prepare that
raw data um for machine learning and
then finally we have to build
kind of some sort of classification
algorithm potentially a regression
um model that will uh kind of identify
um you know a relationship hopefully
uh between our training data
and the labels um so
i think that you know everybody probably
here with us today knows the fun part of
this is
the classification part and maybe your
second
your second runner-up choice of the most
fun part maybe is future
engineering future transformation the
least fun uh
and kind of least exciting part of this
is
that labeled training data part people
uh don't enjoy labeling data um this
is you know it's a slow um a painful
process uh
fortunately you know i think during the
age of abundance
what we saw was this explosion in uh
companies that were offering uh that are
offering
their services to assist in data
labeling
and there actually are a ton of these
companies more than i expected when i
started looking
you know for names and suggestions there
are many many companies that offer
these resources but what i would suggest
is that it's actually better to consider
spending in-house spending time in-house
to develop your own label data
and i think of this phrase from uh
candide
um the book by voltaire
right so we need to tender our own
garden we need to tend to our own
uh harvest um so
you know getting labeled data i think uh
the reason why we would want to cultiva
cultivate our own garden um we we have
seen
kind of this explosion and commercial
providers who do
data annotation data labeling but it can
be quite expensive so
you know just for maybe a hundred
thousand um labeled samples
you could be paying between twenty five
thousand seventy five thousand us
dollars
um and you know honestly as a machine
learning practitioner
you probably already know a hundred
thousand samples may not be
sufficient to train a robust model
especially depending on how
high dimensional and complex your data
set is
and so that's really quite expensive for
a very small data set
another thing to kind of think about is
what's actually happening
at these companies where data is being
labeled there was
this sort of i think shocking article uh
many people found this
article shocking when it came out in
2018
um this alana samuels article the
internet is enabling a new kind of
poorly paid hell
which exposed that these
these services these data labeling
services are actually just employing
very low paid
workers to perform the annotation
and so as you might expect
when you have uh you know non-uh domain
experts
uh labeling data it's likely that the
quality of labels that you're getting
you know especially for
more domain specific data are not gonna
be very effective
um and when workers are being paid very
very low wages to do this kind of
labeling
as you might expect the quality of the
labels are going to vary and so
um you know this is one place where
you might think that you're spending uh
less money by outsourcing this work
outside of your company um but that
outsourcing work actually
can end up becoming a big expenditure if
you have to then
end up re-labeling your data in-house or
abandoning the project altogether
when you see that there's no signal
attached to the labels that you've been
provided
from this external service so
consider labeling your own data um
here's another place where i think we
tend to
end up spending a lot more money and
resources than we
intend to is this question of well which
model
should i use to build um build
this prototype um and you know i'm not
going to pick on any
model type uh here um but what i will
say is that
i have observed in my career of doing
applied machine learning that
people tend to make choices about models
in a very emotional
way right so they they frequently select
models that they have some emotional
attachment to because it's a model that
has been successful for them in the past
on prior projects
um or because it's a model that's kind
of attached to
some sort of glamour um or kind of
exciting
trend um what i what i think is that we
end up spending a lot more
money when we make those uh
model selection decisions in an
emotional way rather than
a scientific way and you know as data
scientists that's sort of where the
scientific
part comes in so you know what i would
say is think about the scientific
process when you're doing model
selection and for one thing
consider the context right so it's not
that a certain
model is going to be the best in all
cases probably
you know a a model might be the best for
this data set that you're working on or
for this problem space that you're
trying to
to solve for in this case and you can
actually test that hypothesis
by doing a comparison here's a
comparison
uh using the yellow brick library um
doing kind of three different
classification models on a single data
set to assess
um which of the models performs the best
and you know i think it's important to
point out that here we see
um a lot of variation um and we see some
cases where there might be some nuance
where
even if a model has a very high f1 score
if our concern really is in avoiding
false positives
um we may actually pick a model
uh kind of on on different on a
different basis
so you know what i'd say is you know do
model selection
um kind of intentionally and
scientifically rather than
um emotionally um you know so
rather than kind of doing what's on the
left-hand side of the screen just
googling what the best model is actually
run
experiments like what's on the right
hand side of the screen where
we select several models and then we use
the data and some kind of cross
validation
measure to systematically determine
the model that is best suited to this
data set
um pick simple models in the beginning
uh
and and try several in parallel identify
the ones that are the best of the ones
that are
are weakest and set an initial baseline
and let that
initial baseline help set the ground
for hyper parameter tuning which comes
next
um so speaking of hyperparameter tuning
this is another place where
we spend as a community of machine
learning practitioners we spend
a lot of time and a lot of resources
and so there are a number of different
ways to do hyper
parameter tuning whether you're kind of
using
the tools that are available in a
library like scikit-learn let's say in
doing something like randomized
search or grid search to using kind of a
bayesian search method
some sort of evolutionary method or
gradient based method
um or whether you are using a you know
quote-unquote auto ml
um you know this is a place where we
spend
a lot of money a lot of time
particularly if you're doing
what's called auto ml which is honestly
really just
usually a combination of the other
things on this list
but done in a black box fashion um
and uh you know where you have to pay a
lot
rather than being able to implement some
of these um
search methods um on your own
uh kind of with more intention about how
you're how you're executing that search
automl tends to be um the most expensive
of all of these uh just because you
can't really tell what's happening under
the hood
um so what i would say is that no matter
what type of hyper parameter tuning
methodology you're using remember
that search is very very difficult and
it gets more difficult
the higher dimensional your data set
becomes
there are many clever optimizations uh
that try to speed
up um the the search process but then
even with those optimizations there's no
guarantee that you'll find a solution
you'll there's no guarantee that you
know if you do find a solution that it's
the optimal solution
um and as your search space gets larger
larger so as your dimensions get bigger
as you have more data
more features and more instances
the amount of time that it takes to do
hyperparameter tuning
increases exponentially
so what to do instead um so if we're
thinking about
a more uh efficient way to do
a hyper perimeter tuning you might think
um
about honestly starting by just reducing
your feature space this can be a way to
dramatically reduce the cost of doing
hyperparameter tuning
what we're looking at here is a yellow
brick visualization
called the recursive feature elimination
visualizer and this wraps
the rfe cv method in scikit-learn and
what it allows us to do is identify
the um the set of features
in our data that is necessary to achieve
some threshold score whether that's your
f1 score or your coefficient
of determination you might also
consider thinking about your train
and test data thinking about how the
model changes
as you give your algorithm more data or
as you take data away
what we're looking at here are yellow
brick learning curve visualizations
for different types of algorithms for
different data sets and thinking about
um you know what happens as we give the
model a little bit more of our data for
training
do we see the training and
cross-validation scores converge
do does one drop while the other
increases
these are things that can help us make
decisions before we spend a lot of time
on hyper parameter tuning to kind of
reduce
that search space and make more
effective choices
um another thing that we might want to
do is really
think deeply about the parameter ranges
that we're searching in when we do
something like a grid search
um you know for for a grid search um
what we
what we were doing is we're setting
multiple different parameter ranges to
explore simultaneously
um but oftentimes before you do that
it's worth it to
explore them individually in a single
parameter range and understand
what that optimal range is to be
searching inside and
that's something that you can do with
this validation curve visualization
which is also from the yellow brick
library so how to do
uh tuning in a more economical uh way
uh well first of all only tune the best
performing models so don't
it's not worth it to do hyper parameter
tuning on all of the models
that you've explored only on the ones
that are best performing
if you can do what you can to reduce
your feature space
either using a future selection or some
kind of feature
engineering or dimensionality reduction
technique make sure you understand the
parameter ranges that you're searching
within and you're not doing it randomly
so you're really thinking about what
what is a sensible
range to be searching within move
towards adding complexity to
a model in a purposeful way so think
about
whether or not the error is coming from
variance or from
bias think about you know if the model
is clearly underfitting that's a good
case
for adding complexity if the error is
not converging that's another
good reason for adding complexity so
make sure you have a good reason for
for adding that complexity and when you
do add complexity do it gradually
and make sure that as you do add
complexity through your hyper parameters
that your train and test scores
are both increasing
another place where i am seeing a lot of
teams
expend a lot of resources in terms of
time and money
is with the development environments
that they choose to use
to do exploratory data analysis
and initial modeling attempts so
i'm seeing more and more teams use
things like
azure data bricks and amazon sage maker
as the initial starting point for
doing kind of an exploration of the
features in a data set
and looking at correlations between
features
and exploring initial models that might
be
a good fit for the data set but what i
would say
is that you know this is generally not
not really necessary so if you consider
that
those conveniences of being able to use
these cloud hosted
tools i i they do add convenience
uh certainly right you don't have to
worry about um configuring spark spark
locally you don't have to
worry about the python version that you
have installed
versus the one that your teammate has
installed that is convenient but
consider
whether or not that's really worth the
expenditure
during an initial prototyping phase
you pay a lot for that convenience in
fact you know every moment
that those notebooks are running in
those cloud-hosted tools you're paying
or your company is paying
those are all opportunities where if you
were just running those notebooks
locally
or exploring um you know the code
locally
in a local development environment
you could potentially be saving a
tremendous amount of money
um and i do hear you know there there
are people who this will say well i
can't do exploratory data analysis
on my local laptop because i'm working
with a massive data set
um and in those cases what i would say
is um
okay well have you tried done down
sampling uh
you know it's actually extremely cheap
to just take a very small random sample
of your data to perform some initial
exploratory analysis and what you might
find is that you can conduct a lot of
your preliminary experiments
locally before you move things to the
cloud and
you know i i certainly as a
applied machine learning practitioner i
understand that you know at some point
we often do have to move everything to
the cloud so that we can kind of have
our
code running as microservices in a
you know robust scalable way
but you know that initial prototyping
step uh oftentimes can happen locally
um consider also that um
you know some of the tools that we're
using
um lend themselves to
bad habits they give us very limited
memory there's a quote by george
santayana
that those who cannot remember the past
are condemned to repeat it
you know for those of us who do
exploration
in machine learning i think a lot of
times that
condemnation manifests
something like this where you'll be
working inside a jupiter notebook
you'll be exploring some models uh
you've been running your notebook for
a while um you have uh done a tremendous
amount of
feature engineering and exploration and
at some point something goes wrong with
the notebook and you're unable to
recover some of your data so whether or
not that means you've lost
the model or the progress of the model
if something crashed part way through
if you lost kind of your intermediate
future
engineering components whether you lost
the final model
consider that all of the time that goes
into that development
is has a cost and there is
a cost aside from just being embarrassed
at the end
there's a cost that's associated with
losing
losing data so one thing that i would
suggest and this is something that you
can do kind of in the context of
whatever your ide is
whether it's hosted whether it's local
whether it's a jupiter notebook or
python scripts or something else
get into the habit of serializing
everything
so make sure there are checkpoints in
your code where you're serializing not
just the model but any
engineered features so that could be
future vectors it could be embedding
spaces
store the stop words that you've
identified as being really
um meaningful uh in your context for
removing
things and and making sure the important
words
bubble to the top you can serialize any
lexicons that you've developed serialize
the scores of your models right so not
just
the pickle let's say but also
the scores that are associated with that
saved model
you can also save all of the diagnostic
plots that you've done
using seabourn or matplotlib or
yellowbrick
you can save those diagnostic plots help
you remember
how the model that you're saving was
performing
the other big thing that i see a team
sort of forget to do is to
to serialize and track the training time
so if you end up with two models that
perform
approximately the same one of the best
ways to
pick the the one to use in production is
the one that has the shortest training
time but if you haven't saved
um the time that it took to go into
training the model it's going to be hard
for somebody downstream or even for you
a few days later to remember
which of the models was the quicker one
so finally i think that um you know a
big tip for
for being more cost conscious with
machine learning
is having a definition of done you know
this is something that comes from
the agile kind of methodology having a
definition of done um i understand that
it's much
more difficult with machine learning
because there are so many
um there's so much unpredictability
uncertainty that comes along with doing
machine learning
um but uh with practice i think that you
can start to identify some of these
things before you've even gotten started
right so you know is there a certain
accuracy measure that you can use as a
threshold even if it's a low one
uh right just one that sort of
demonstrates that there is some signal
in this data um or if this is a model
that you've been
tuning um have your is there a
an error bound that you are comfortable
with right so
you know of course if you keep tuning
you'll probably be able to keep reducing
the error
uh indefinitely but you know is there a
bound
uh where you can be comfortable as a
stopping point
um you know is there some convergence
that we can use
um to demonstrate that we've we've
achieved the the initial goals
or um is this modeling effort
merely a spike in our sprint and because
the sprint is over we can
close this bike um at least for now uh
and then decide what to do in our next
sprint and of course sometimes the
project is just due
um so so be thinking about
this definition of done and you know be
thinking about
how you can practice this um
you know agile methodology in the
context of machine learning where
you know the goal is to uh
continuously improve but intentionally
improve in the context of sort of
structured
uh sprints and cycles rather than just
sort of an indefinite loop where we just
try to keep getting better and better
and better
with no clear end in sight
so uh in closing what i would like to
suggest is that um you know
our practice in the you know these years
of uh overabundance have
led us to the relentless pursuit
of accuracy um as being kind of the most
important thing uh in all cases right
where
you know there's been um you know i
think an interest
in in selecting data sets or selecting
projects where you know that you'll be
able to get
a high accuracy score or you know that
you know you'll be able to publish a
paper that shows you can get a
little bit higher accuracy score than
the last people did
but consider what would happen if we
shifted
our mindset away from that relentless
pursuit of a tiny tiny bit more accuracy
towards model thriftiness right so if
the goal was
you know not to be the last person
who was able to train a model on this
data set but instead
to have some kind of benefit to your
organization
instead you know find some way to save
time for your organization
and keep your organization going during
these lean times ahead
think of all these new projects that we
might work on all these new things that
we might discover
if we if we were able to shift over to
this different way of thinking
i thank you very much for
coming to my talk watching my talk um
and for
considering these best practices and
following along on this uh journey um i
hope that
uh some of you will be interested in
joining my faq session you can look on
the pi data
global website to find out when those
faqs will be scheduled and i hope there
will be one
that works in your time zone and if you
are not able to attend and you want to
connect with me on social
again my contact information is pretty
consistent
across all of the platforms thank you
again and i hope you have a wonderful
conference goodbye